la sb1 ya es ley en Texas el gobernador
Greg abbott promulgó una reforma a las
leyes electorales del Estado una
normativa que según los republicanos
ayudará a combatir el fraude
la ley dificulta la emisión de votos
fraudulentos un área en la que será más
difícil engañar es la de los votos por
correo
entre otras medidas esta nueva ley
prohíbe votar desde un automóvil limita
la posibilidad de votar las 24 horas del
día
exige identificación a la hora de emitir
votos por correo convierte en delito
para los funcionarios el envío de
papeletas no solicitadas previamente por
el votante y empodera a los observadores
electorales partidistas según el centro
brenan para la Justicia con Texas y ya
son 18 los estados que han implementado
restricciones al voto tras las
elecciones de 2020 en las que el ex
presidente Donald Trump denunció fraude
sin ofrecer pruebas y un ataque a la
democracia para los demócratas que
exigen acción del congreso para una
Protección Federal Texas acaba de hacer
que votar sea más difícil uniéndose a
Georgia y otros estados en la
reescritura de las reglas electorales
después de las últimas elecciones
nuestra democracia está bajo ataque y el
senado debe actuar para proteger el
derecho al voto lo antes posible los
críticos han denunciado que esta serie
de medidas afectará
desproporcionadamente a los votantes
afroe estadounidenses y latinos en julio
los legisladores demócratas abandonaron
Texas en un intento por evitar que la
controvertida ley fuera votada una
maniobra que solo logró retrasar el
proceso pero no bloquearlo